[音楽]
はいというポストですあの街によくポスト見かけると思うんですよ
ポスト
こんな感じだと思うんですねパッと見で今年の夏は普通の夏よりも違って便着ず気温が
高い
中傷とか危ないしみんなあったんでちょっと頭がおかしくなってると思うんですよやば
いって温度は
ね温度本当に os やホはでは行ったで普段こんな格好してポストの隣にいたら
さすがに何が何でもまつげられないと思うんですけどコーナーは猛暑
クスは水このなぜならばポストのことに僕がいても僕をポンとか間違えて僕に手紙を
投函すると思うんですよ
あ確かにブエナがちょっと厚着でボートセット英語+達したけどちょっとずつ町内誰か
僕に手紙を投函するまで帰れま10やっていこうと思います
方から話
方が全体大丈夫か熱いも今年の夏はみんなバーガー
みんなバカなんでお年だったか早速ちょっとぽその通りに行こうと思いますでは曇り
けど編
あでも透明だとポーストレスってやっぱり
間違えるんだからいや完全にポストですねこれ
あって神だしたくなっちゃう安全にバスト放送えっ
やってとストが歩くなんてことないですからこればかりは盗撮されても何も言えばまあ
確かに a まずだぜいます金って神よ r あーてかそもそもってこと
そもそもです今の木はもうハイテクですからねじゃあメールだからねぇ
めっちゃそうされた今フォンと動いたら盗撮したくなりますよね違った思うのだからね
俺の人権が年だ
おばあちゃんに鼻で笑われましてすごい笑顔だったか雪と笑顔にするポッドつのない
感じです
スタークエストですねはい仲間が見えていますそれ
俺膝を打っ
ああああああ
夢道路のど番台の車止めてたよどうですか
身長差が直行
あっあぱっと見わからないです
所完全に一緒ですわかんないです手紙の方しちゃったよええ
会え者優しいポスター pot なんてん
はいチーズ4日
ok すれば分かる人には分かるんですねとまあ完全に完全にいっしょねー
これは普通に間違いますねカメラ5とにゃんて離れてちょっと待ってみましょう
昔は退けました
1ん
ん
ません
[音楽]
ん
dj をやってい
voodoo
られたポーズ海辺ならホストって使えるいやだからこいつ相当すごいですよやばいよ
よくやっては見習い本とおっしゃってイヤーて言っない
そもそもですよね
あーダメダメですじゃんですよ彼こそ休憩しないですよ
あったよ見てほしいですあっ茶席
[音楽]
web
den den
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
al 2
par
ああああああああ
ああ
バーン
ん
eonia
ティーガーのぞよ
えっ
お前もありがとうって
使えるねっ